oh the seashore
the waves the water
the seaweed
the sh sheep
are they eating seaweed
we gotta figure this out
[Music]
so here's a little context to start off
the story
we're in an island high high high up in
scotland called north ronald z it's so
remote you can only get here by ferry or
airplane
and on this small picturesque island
home to only 50 people lives a very
very rare breed of sheep
the seaweed sheep
[Music]
meet kevin the authority on all things
seaweed sheep
i am kevin woodbridge i'm the clerk to
the north romney sheep court which is a
fairly anciently established management
committee for all things sheep on the
island
so let's learn more about this rare
species
welcome to seaweed sheep 101
[Music]
the chief investors have come into town
probably a thousand two thousand years
ago there was an orkney native breed
originally but these have branched off
into their own unique
niche which is just to live on seaweed
they are smaller than the average sheep
and their wool can be black white gray
or brown the males have big curly horns
and so do some females
and
they're only on northerners it's the
only place you can find them in the
world
[Music]
in about the early 19th century they
were slowly excluded to the fortuna to
preserve the more fertile land in land
for cattle as a result the sheep were
confined to the seashore and were forced
to survive on seaweed this changed their
digestive system over time making them
one of only two animals in the world who
are able to survive on seaweed alone and
this wall known as the sheepdike makes
sure they stay on the shore right kevin
yes yes but um i think perhaps my
daughter heather's the best person to
speak to about that
okay well heather over to you
behind me is the native sheepdike
this was constructed in 1832. the north
romsley sheepdike is essential in the
genetic structure of the sheep
northern sheep have a very high
intolerance to copper so they die from
over nutrition by grazing on the grass
for too long so we keep them on the
shore and they eat seaweed which has got
very low levels of iodine and copper
[Music]
the community has been very concentrated
on preserving and then developing the
sheep the planting is obviously a big
community activity it takes everyone in
the island to turn out and chase them
along the beach and
clip them up and so on i think in many
ways they define the island it's very
much embedded in the in the island
culture and that's the heritage of the
island we need to preserve
[Music]
you